SHOULD NEVER BE TRUSTED AGAIN,
ALONG WITH MAKING A SCENE AND IN
SO MANY OTHERS.
JOINING US NOW, EXCLUSIVELY ON
THE PHONE, IS THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
>> President Trump: WELL,
THANK YOU, SEAN, VERY MUCH.
IT'S AN HONOR.
>> Sean: I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE.
YOU REALLY HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REACT AND RESPOND
TO THE MUELLER REPORT, THE AG'S
LETTER, THAT SUMMARIZED THE
REPORT THAT EXONERATED YOU, NO
COLLUSION AFTER ALL THESE YEARS,
AS YOU HAVE BEEN CLAIMING.
HE LEFT THE DECISION AS IT
REMAINS TO OBSTRUCTION TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THEY QUICKLY SAID NO, THAT DOES
NOT RISE TO THE LEVEL, AND HE
WANTED TO GET YOUR REACTION.
>> President Trump: WELL, WE
ARE VERY HAPPY ABOUT IT.
IT'S GONE ON FOR A LONG TIME,
ALMOST SINCE THE BEGINNING OF MY
TERM, AND YOU KNOW, IF YOU LOOK
AT IT, WE'VE DONE SO MUCH
DESPITE THAT.
IT WAS A CLOUD, IT WAS A CLOUD
THAT MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T BELIEVE,
FORTUNATELY.
THEY SPENT MORE THAN
$30 MILLION, HUNDREDS OF
INTERVIEWS OF PEOPLE, IN SOME
CASES VERY INNOCENT PEOPLE THAT
WERE PUT THROUGH THE RINGER.
MILLIONS OF DOCUMENT PAGES,
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOCUMENT PAGES, AND AFTER THAT,
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, THERE
WAS NO OBSTRUCTION.
IT WAS SUCH A RIDICULOUS THING
THAT HAPPENED ON THE OTHER HAND,
YOU LOOK AT HOW DID THIS
START.
HOW DID THAT START?
YOU HAVE DIRTY COPS, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ABOUT FBI FOLKS.
I KNOW SO MANY, THEY ARE
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE, BUT AT THE
TOP, THEY WERE NOT CLEAN, TO PUT
IT MILDLY.
WHAT THEY DID TO OUR COUNTRY WAS
A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE THING.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, WE
TALKED A LOT ON THIS PROGRAM AND
ABOUT THE FISA ABUSE SCANDAL.
THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW, THAT IN
AUGUST OF 2016, WE KNOW BRUCE
OHR WARNED EVERYONE AT THE DOJ
AND THE FBI THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HATED YOU, THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER, THAT IT WAS NOT
VERIFIED, BUT STILL IN OCTOBER,
AND THEN THREE RENEWAL
APPLICATION WARRANTS APPROVED,
THEY WERE TOLD BY THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO THE BULK OF
INFORMATION CAME FROM THAT PHONY
DOSSIER, ANDREW McCABE SAID NO
DOSSIER, NO FISA WARRANT.
THERE WERE RUSSIAN LIES
DISSEMINATED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BEFORE THE ELECTION, BUT
IT ALSO VIOLATED THE RIGHTS OF
CARTER PAGE AND GAVE A BACKDOOR
INTO YOUR CAMPAIGN FOR SPYING,
WHICH ANOTHER MEDIA MADE FUN OF
AT THE TIME, WHEN YOU SAID IT
HAPPENED.
>> President Trump: WHEN I
SAID THERE COULD BE SOMEBODY
SPYING ON MY CAMPAIGN, A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENED.
IT WAS LIKE -- IT WENT WILD OUT
THERE.
THEY COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT I
COULD SAY SUCH A THING.
AS IT TURNED OUT, THAT WAS A
SMALL POTATOES COMPARED TO WHAT
WENT ON.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED,
AND WHEN IT HAPPENED, AND THE
MONEY THAT WAS SPENT, THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS ON THE
PHONY DOSSIER, AND THEN THEY
USED THE DOSSIER TO START
THINGS, AND THERE WAS NO TRUTH
WHATSOEVER.
IT WAS A FRAUD AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND PAID FOR BY
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE DNC.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
IF YOU WROTE THIS AS A NOVEL, NO
ONE WOULD BUY IT.
IT WOULD BE A FAILURE BECAUSE IT
WILL BE TOO UNBELIEVABLE.
NO ONE WOULD BELIEVE IS POSSIBLE
TO THINK THIS WENT ON.
WE ARE GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT, AND IT'S GOT TO BE -- I
MEAN, YOU CAN NEVER ALLOW THIS
TO HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT.
THIS CAN NEVER, EVER HAPPEN TO A
PRESIDENT AGAIN, SEAN.
THAT WAS A DISGRACE AND
EMBARRASSMENT OUR COUNTRY, THAT
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO GET AWAY
WITH THIS.
HOPEFULLY THEY WON'T GET AWAY
WITH IT.
>> Sean: DO YOU NOW FEEL
VINDICATED?
WAS THERE ANYTHING THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S REPORT -- I
KNOW YOU HAVE CALLED FOR
OBVIOUSLY THE WHOLE MUELLER MEMO
TO BE RELEASED, DID ANYTHING
SURPRISE YOU?
AND WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN ALL OF
THIS?
>> President Trump: WELL,
PEOPLE WERE HURT SO BADLY, SO
BADLY.
THEIR LIVES HAVE BEEN RUINED.
AND OVER -- OVER SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER TAKEN PLACE,
AN INVESTIGATION THAT SHOULD
HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
THERE WAS NO CRIME, AS YOU KNOW.
YOU ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO DO THIS
LEGALLY IF THERE IS A CRIME.
THERE WAS NO CRIME.
THEY'VE ALL ADMITTED IT.
COMEY, WHO IS A TERRIBLE GUY,
COMEY AND McCABE AND STRZOK
AND PAGE, THE LOVER, PAIGE, AND
ALL THESE
PEOPLE, THEY'VE ADMITTED AN
TESTIMONY THAT THERE WAS NO
CRIME.
SO THEY'D STARTED AN
INVESTIGATION BASED ON NO CRIME.
I WILL SAY THIS, OUR NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BILL BARR, IS
A GREAT GENTLEMAN.
I'VE HEARD ABOUT HIM FOR YEARS.
HE'S A GREAT MAN.
HAD HE BEEN THERE INITIALLY,
THIS ALL WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
BECAUSE WHAT HAS GONE ON THERE
IS JUST A DISGRACE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT --
>> President Trump: >
>> President Trump: P
>> President Trump: e
>> President Trump: i
>> President Trump: t
>> President Trump: T
>> President Trump: u
>> President Trump: A
>> President Trump: L
>> President Trump: T
>> President Trump: O
>> President Trump: F
INNOCENT PEOPLE WERE HURT VERY
BADLY, AND IT'S VERY, VERY SAD
ACTUALLY.
>> Sean: FOR THIS TO NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE PATH IS TO GETTING TO THAT
POINT?
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT YOU BELIEVE NEED
TO BE PUT IN PLACE SO THAT A
FISA COURT, IN THIS CASE, IT IS
NOT TOLD HILLARY PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES, ITS OWN AUTHOR
DOESN'T STAND BY IT, BUT YET IT
WAS USED TO OBTAIN FOUR FISA
WARRANTS THAT IT GAVE A BACKDOOR
TO YOUR CAMPAIGN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN TO PREVENT THIS FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN?
WHAT CHECKS AND BALANCES, AND
WHAT SHOULD BE PURSUED OR NOT
PURSUED IN YOUR OPINION?
>> President Trump: WELL, I'M
GOING TO LEAVE THAT TO OUR NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHO HAS BEEN
SO INCREDIBLE, ACTUALLY.
THAT'S BASED ON A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAYING, THIS IS A VERY, VERY
SPECIAL PERSON.
THAT IS WHAT YOU NEED IN THAT
POSITION.
THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
YOU NEED TO SO MANY DIFFERENT
UNIQUE, GENIUS, YOU NEED
RATIONALITY, YOU NEED DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF GOOD.
I'M ALSO GOING TO LEAVE IT TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HE'S HEAD OF JUDICIARY AND
SENATE AND A VERY, VERY GOOD GUY
AND A VERY SMART GUY.
I'M JUST GOING TO LET THEM DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO, AND I
WOULD IMAGINE THEY DON'T LIKE
WHAT THEY SEE, TO PUT IT MILDLY.
BUT YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK THEM.
I THINK IT IS MUCH MORE
APPROPRIATE -- I PURPOSELY DID
NOT WANT TO INVOLVE MYSELF IN
THIS WHOLE THING.
I WANTED TO LET OTHER PEOPLE DO
IT.
AND I WISH HE DIDN'T TAKE SO
LONG.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
REALLY LONGER THAN, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, LONGER THAN MUELLER --
IT WAS MANY MONTHS BEFORE THAT
THAT STRZOK AND PAGE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE INSURANCE
POLICY.
THE INSURANCE POLICY, JUST IN
CASE HILLARY CLINTON LOST.
THEY WANTED AN INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST ME.
AND WHAT WE WERE PLAYING OUT
UNTIL JUST RECENTLY WAS THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
THEY WANTED TO DO A SUBVERSION.
IT WAS TREASON.
IT WAS REALLY TREASON.
IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAD DONE
THIS TO THE DEMOCRATS, IF WE HAD
DONE THIS TO PRESIDENT OBAMA,
YOU'D HAVE 100 PEOPLE IN JAIL
RIGHT NOW AND IT WOULD BE
TREASON.
IT WOULD BE CONSIDERED TREASON
AND THEY WOULD BE IN JAIL FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
BUT IT WORKED OUT THE OTHER WAY,
AND, YOU KNOW, IT JUST IS REALLY
A HORRIBLE SITUATION.
AND AN INCREDIBLE OUTCOME, OR
CERTAINLY VERY CLOSE TO AN
OUTCOME, AND WE'LL HAVE TO SEE
HOW IT ALL STARTED.
BUT I'M GOING TO LEAVE THAT TO
OTHER PEOPLE, INCLUDING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND OTHERS, TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION.
BUT IT'S VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR COUNTRY TO KNOW, BECAUSE
IN 50 YEARS FROM NOW, AND 100
YEARS FROM NOW, IF SOMEONE TRIES
THE SAME THING, THEY HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THE PENALTY WILL BE
VERY, VERY GREAT, IF AND WHEN
THEY GET CAUGHT.
>> Sean: BEFORE I GET TO THE
MEDIA QUESTION, WOULD YOU
CONSIDER, SIR, A PARDON?
LOOK AT GENERAL FLYNN FOR
EXAMPLE.
OR PAPADOPOULOS, WHO HAS HAD TO
SPEND 12 DAYS IN JAIL.
IS THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD CONSIDER AT SOME POINT?
>> President Trump: WELL, AS I
TOLD YOU, MANY, MANY PEOPLE WERE
HURT, INCREDIBLY HURT BY THIS
WHOLE SCAM, JUST A SCAM.
BUT IT'S MUCH WORSE THAN THAT.
IT'S AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL, AND
THE IMPORTANCE IS SO -- WHAT IT
MEANT OUR COUNTRY, IT'S A VERY,
VERY DARK.
MACK, AND
I THINK MAYBE WE ARE SHEDDING A
LOT OF LIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO COME INTO A
BRIGHT, BEAUTIFUL, SUNNY DAY.
BUT WHEN YOU MENTION
GENERAL FLYNN, HE WAS A MAN WHO
HAD AN INCREDIBLE RECORD IN THE
MILITARY, YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENED
TO HIM.
THE FBI SAID HE WASN'T LYING, AS
I UNDERSTAND IT, AND IF THE
MUELLER GROUP SAID HE WAS LYING,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT HE HAS GONE
THROUGH, AND WHAT SO MANY OTHERS
HAVE GONE THROUGH.
I COULD NAME NAMES THAT WOULD
JUST GO ON FOR THE ENTIRE --
YOUR ENTIRE SHOW.
IT'S A VERY, VERY SAD THING.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
PARDONS NOW BUT I CAN SAY, IT IS
SO SAD THAT SO MANY LEVELS.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, I
BELIEVE YOU PROBABLY HAVE
FOREVER BRANDED FAKE NEWS FAKE
NEWS.
I'M NOT SURE IF SOME OF THESE
COMPANIES WILL EVER RECOVER.
I TALKED EARLIER IN MY MONOLOGUE
ABOUT, I DON'T REALLY RECALL
THEM EVER TALKING ABOUT RECORD
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT, AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HAS BEEN AMERICANS
, ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, REALLY AMAZING
NUMBERS.
BUT I SEE EVERY SECOND, MINUTE,
HOUR, EVERY DAY, THERE ARE
ATTACKS.
I WILL TELL YOU A SMALL SNIPPET.
I'M ONLY PICKING ONE NETWORK IN
THIS CASE, CNN.
JUST A SMALL SNIPPET OF SOME OF
THE COVERAGE AND SPECULATION AND
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID ABOUT
YOU AND WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION.
>> RUSSIAN OPERATIVES CLAIM TO
HAVE COMPROMISING PERSONAL AND
FINANCIAL INFORMATION ABOUT
MR. TRUMP.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THOSE AROUND HIM DURING THE
ELECTION CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER TO
UNDERMINE THE BASIS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> IT DOES LOOK LIKE COLLUSION,
IT DOES LOOK LIKE HE'S LISTENING
TO PUTIN MORE THAN HE IS
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE.
AS THEY GO SO THIS PICTURE THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS SO
DESPERATE TO AVOID, THIS PICTURE
OF COLLUSION, BEGINS TO FILL IN.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEES THE WALLS
ARE CLOSING IN AND HE'S LASHING
OUT.
>> HE'S DESPERATE.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY FLAILING AROUND
BECAUSE HE FEELS THE WALLS
CLOSING IN.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I
COULD PLAY AN HOUR WORTH OF
COVERAGE OF THAT, FOR TWO YEARS
IT'S GONE ON.
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER?
WHAT IS A REACTION TO THE MEDIA?
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN VERY
CRITICAL.
FAKE NEWS.
>> President Trump: AS MANY
PEOPLE HAVE SAID, AND
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE HAD SOME
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
WERE FAIR.
WHEN YOU MENTIONED RUSH OR MARK
LEVIN, OR STEVE DOOCY, AND
AINSLEY IN THE MORNING, AND
BRIAN AND LAURA, JESSE,
JEANINE -- I HOPE SHE'S BACK
SOON.
>> Sean: SHE'S BACK SATURDAY.
>> President Trump: SO MANY
PEOPLE.
I DON'T WANT TO KEEP GOING
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO LEAVE OUT
SOME PEOPLE.
I COULD AGAIN GO SO LONG.
SO MANY GREAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
BEEN -- THEY GET AT.
NOBODY HAS BEEN TOUGHER, NOBODY,
ON RUSSIA, THEN ME.
AND EVERYBODY -- MY ENEMIES SAY
THAT, WHEN THEY ARE REASONABLE
ENEMIES, WHEN THEY ARE FAIR.
YOU LOOK AT THE PIPELINE,
EXPOSING THAT GOING INTO
GERMANY.
YOU LOOK AT OIL WITH THE NUMBER
ONE -- I MEAN, IT IS WHAT WE
HAVE DONE WITH ENERGY, AND OIL
AND GAS AND THAT IS ALL
COMPETITION FROM -- FOR RUSSIA.
YOU LOOK AT THE UKRAINE, YOU
LOOK AT SO MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS.
YOU LOOK AT OUR MILITARY.
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN POWERED BY WIND, WHICH
WOULDN'T HAVE WORKED, BY THE
WAY, BECAUSE IT ONLY BLOWS IT
SOMETIMES, AND LOTS OF PROBLEMS
COME ABOUT.
BUT WE ARE STRONGER NOW AS A
COUNTRY THEN WE HAVE EVER BEEN.
WE ARE DOING BETTER FINANCIALLY
THAN WE HAVE EVER DONE, OUR
MARKETS ARE HEADING RECORDS ALL
THE TIME, I HAVE MANY, MANY
RECORDS OF THE HIGHEST STOCK
MARKET.
PEOPLE'S 401(K)S ARE DOING
BETTER THAN THEY HAVE EVER DONE
BY FAR.
IT'S UP ALMOST 50% FROM THE TIME
I AM ELECTED PRESIDENT, AND
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE WAY DOWN.
YOU LOOK AT CHINA AS AN EXAMPLE,
WE ARE NEGOTIATING A DEAL WITH
CHINA, WE WILL MAKE A VERY GOOD
DEAL WITH CHINA.
CHINA IS WAY DOWN.
WE ARE WAY UP.
BUT NOBODY HAS BEEN TOUGHER TO
RUSSIA OR ON RUSSIA THAN
DONALD TRUMP, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOBODY EVEN CLOSE.
AND YET, WITH ALL OF THAT, WE
WANT TO HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
WE WANT TO HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE SMART TO
DO.
WE'LL DO GREAT WITH IT.
BUT NOBODY HAS BEEN TOUGHER.
AND WHEN I WATCHED ALL OF THIS
NONSENSE, IT WAS FAKE NEWS, JUST
TERRIBLE FAKE NEWS, GOOD NEWS
IS, BASED ON POLES AND BASED ON
OTHER THINGS
, BASED ON WHERE WE STAND NOW
WITH THE PUBLIC, SEAN, THE
PEOPLE NEVER BOUGHT IT.
THEY GET WHAT'S HAPPENING.
OUR COUNTRY IS DOING
FANTASTICALLY WELL.
MORE REGULATIONS CUT THAN ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT, AND THAT IS
ONLY IN TWO YEARS.
NOBODY'S COME EVEN CLOSE.
THE BIG TAX CUTS, SO MANY THINGS
WE ARE GOING TO DO, AND CREDIBLE
HEALTH CARE THAT THE DEMOCRATS,
FRANKLY, WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW HOW
TO DO.
WE ALL BECOME THE PARTY OF
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLY
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLG
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLO
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLD
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLH
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLA
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALLE
HEALTH CARE, THE PARTY OF REALL.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH AND WE HAVE
SO MUCH PLANNED.
SO WHEN I HAD TO LISTEN TO CNN,
WHICH IS SO, SO FAKE, SO
HORRIBLY FAKE, I WOULDN'T LISTEN
OFTEN -- BELIEVE ME, I WOULDN'T
WANT TO LISTEN OFTEN.
BUT WHENEVER I DID, WHENEVER I
THOUGHT, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
AND MSNBC, THE SAME THING.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, I HEARD THEIR
RATINGS LAST NIGHT, BOTH OF THEM
WERE -- THEY DROPPED OFF THE
FOLDER.
THEY DROPPED TO A LEVEL THAT NO
ONE COULD BELIEVE BECAUSE NOW
THAT THEY SEE THE MUELLER
REPORT, WHERE YOU LOOK AT THEIR
FINDING, I MEAN, THE FINDING WAS
VERY, VERY STRONG.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION, NO
RUSSIA, NO NOTHING.
IT'S GREAT.
I NOTICE YOUR RECORD, YOU HAD
VIRTUALLY RECORD RATINGS LAST
NIGHT.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE
CREDIBILITY.
SO I WANT TO THINK BOX, I WANT
TO THANK
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE I JUST
NAMED, BUT ALSO MANY OTHERS,
THEY HAVE BEEN SO FANTASTIC TO
ME.
AND REALLY TO OUR COUNTRY, AND I
REALLY DO -- THEY ARE REALLY
AMAZING PEOPLE, GREAT PEOPLE.
IT WASN'T SO EASY FOR THEM.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, ONE
THING I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
OFTEN, AND I HONESTLY DON'T SEE
IT
ELSEWHERE IN THE MEDIA, YOU DID
KEEP YOUR PROMISE ON YOUR TAX
CUTS.
YOU DID SUCH RECORDS, ENDING
BUREAUCRATIC REGULATION, JUDGES,
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, TRADE DEAL
DEALS, BEING TOUGH ON IRAN,
JERUSALEM IS NOW THE CAPITAL,
ALL THOSE THINGS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU -- ESPECIALLY
IN A MINUTE -- ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AND HEALTH CARE.
I WANT TO FIRST RUN DOWN SOME
NAMES AND GET YOUR THOUGHTS.
JAMES COMEY TONIGHT IN AN
INTERVIEW SUGGESTED MAYBE HE WAS
FIRED FOR OBSTRUCTION.
I JUST PLAYED A TAPE OF HIM
SAYING THAT HE COULD BE FIRED
ANYTIME FOR ANY REASON OR NO
REASON.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON JAMES COMEY?
>> President Trump: WELL, HE'S
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
FOR ANY REASON.
IF YOU LOOK AT ARTICLE TWO, FOR
ANY REASON.
DESPITE THAT, THAT WAS AN
INCORRECT STATEMENT.
WHEN YOU SAY WHAT I SAID, THERE
WAS NOTHING SAID WRONG THERE BUT
THEY DID NOT PLAY THE WHOLE
INTERVIEW.
WHEN THEY PLAY THE WHOLE THING,
YOU SEE EXACTLY, I MEAN, THE
FACT IS, IT WOULD ONLY GET
WORSE.
AND I SAID THIS.
IT WOULD ONLY GET WORSE IF I
FIRED HIM.
I KNEW THAT IT WAS GOING TO GET
WORSE, NOT BETTER.
I'M NOT GOING TO FIRE HIM AND
EVERYTHING GOES AWAY.
IT WOULD BE A BIGGER DEAL IF I
FIRED HIM, AND I DO THAT.
SO IT WAS A NEGATIVE, NOT A
POSITIVE.
AND EVERYBODY KNEW THAT.
BUT NBC DIDN'T WANT TO PLAY IT
THAT WAY.
THEY WANTED TO PLAYED A
DIFFERENT WAY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT PEOPLE THAT
ARE DISHONEST, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT BAD, FAKE NEWS, NBC, WHERE
WE HAD THE     "THE APPRENTICE"F
WE HAD THE     "THE APPRENTICE"R
WE HAD THE     "THE APPRENTICE"M
WE HAD THE     "THE APPRENTICE"N
WE HAD THE     "THE APPRENTICE"Y
YEARS AS ONE OF THEIR MOST
SUCCESSFUL SHOWS, NBC IS AS BAD
TO CNN, I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
>> Sean: ADAM SCHIFF IS SAYING
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
I THINK ONE OF THE FUNNIEST
TAPES I HAVE PLAYED IN THE SHOW
EVER IS A HOAX, YOU HAVE A
RUSSIAN TALKING ABOUT
COMPROMISING MATERIAL ON A NAKED
TRUMP, HE THINKS IT'S SHOWN TO
PUTIN, AND HE IS LITERALLY
COLLUDING TO GET INFORMATION AND
SO HE CAN IMPACT THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM.
BUT HE IS STILL TO THIS DAY, NOW
PRIOR TO THE MUELLER CONCLUSION,
THAT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION,
NONE.
IT WAS QUOTED IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S REPORT.
WE HAD A NINE-MONTH FBI
INVESTIGATION.
THEY SAID NO COLLUSION.
LISA PAGE AND PETER STRZOK SAID
NO COLLUSION.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE SAID NO
COLLUSION.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE SAID NO
THAT IS ALL BEFORE TWO YEARS OF
MUELLER.
BUT THE OUTCOME THIS GUY IS
STILL PUSHING THIS CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
THOUGHTS ON ADAM SCHIFF?
>> President Trump: WELL,
SCHIFF IS A BAD GUY.
HE KNEW HE WAS LYING.
HE'S NOT A DUMMY.
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF, HE WOULD
GO ON AND JUST LIE AND LIE AND
LEAK AND CALL UP CNN AND OTHERS
AND JUST -- YOU KNOW, I WATCH
HIM, SO SANCTIMONIOUS, AND GETS
ON AND SAYS, OH, WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT RUSSIA.
HE KNEW IT WAS A LIE AND HE
WOULD GET INTO THE BACK ROOM
WITH HIS FRIENDS AND THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, AND THEY WOULD
LAUGH LIKE HELL AT WHAT THEY
WERE DOING, IS A DISGRACE.
HE KNEW IT WAS ALIVE.
THEREFORE, IN ONE WAY, YOU COULD
SAY IT'S A CRIME WHAT HE DID,
BECAUSE HE WAS MAKING HORRIBLE
STATEMENTS THAT HE KNEW WERE
FALSE, AND FRANKLY, I HEARD THEY
SHOULD FORCE THEM OFF THE
COMMITTEE, OR IF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR.
HE SHOULD BE FORCED OUT OF
OFFICE.
HE IS A DISGRACE TO OUR COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE PLENTY OF OTHERS.
BUT HE WOULD GO ON NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT, TALKING ABOUT COLLUSION,
THE COLLUSION DELUSION.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS ABOUT
RUSSIA, IF THEY HAD ANYTHING ON
ME, IT WOULD HAVE COME OUT A
LONG TIME AGO.
PROBABLY A LONG TIME BEFORE I
RAN BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
MUCH BETTER OFF.
I HOPE WE REALLY GET ALONG WELL
WITH THEM BUT THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN A LOT BETTER OFF WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AS PRESIDENT, IN
TERMS OF ENERGY, IN TERMS OF OIL
AND GAS, LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE
DOING WITH THE ENERGY.
IT'S INCREDIBLE IN OUR COUNTRY.
BUT THAT'S --
>> Sean: FIRST TIME AT 75
YEARS --
>> President Trump: HILLARY
WOULDN'T LET YOU DRILL, THERE
WOULD BE NO OIL, THERE WOULD BE
NO GAS, THERE WOULDN'T BE
ANYTHING TO COMPETE.
RUSSIA, IF THEY WERE AT ALL FOR
ME -- BY THE WAY, IF YOU LOOK AT
ALL OF THE THINGS, THEY WERE
SORT OF FOR AND AGAINST BOTH,
NOT JUST ONE WAY -- BUT YOU LOOK
AT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT THINGS,
NOT RUSSIA MUCH RATHER HAVE
HILLARY THAN DONALD TRUMP.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU COME AFTER THE
ELECTION, I REMEMBER, IT WAS A
LITTLE SURPRISED BECAUSE I KNOWT
LITTLE SURPRISED BECAUSE I KNOWA
A LOT OF THE CROWDS -- YOU
HAD A LOT OF BIG CROWDS, CHANTED
"LOCK HER UP" ON HILLARY COME
AFTER THE ELECTION, YOU SAID,
LET'S MOVE ON.
DO YOU FEEL THAT WAY TODAY?
>> President Trump: NO, NOT
REALLY.
I DID FEEL THAT WAY VERY MUCH,
THE NIGHT I WON, THEY WERE ALL
SCREAMING "LOCKER UP, LOCKER
UP."
THEY DELETED 33,000 EMAILS, AND
THEY WERE BLEACH BUT, THAT IS A
BIG DEAL, A VERY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS, AND ALMOST NOBODY DOES
IT BECAUSE IT IS SO EXPENSIVE.
THAT IS THE WAY YOU REALLY GET
RID OF IT.
SO SHE DELETED 33,000 EMAILS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I DID THAT?
SUPPOSING I DID THAT, I GAVE
MILLIONS OF PAGES TO THESE
PEOPLE --
>> Sean: 1.5 MILLION.
>> President Trump: THE CASE
THAT WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION, AND ANOTHER
CASE, ALAN WISEMAN,
YOU KNOW ALL ABOUT HIM, AND MANY
OTHERS.
WE GAVE MILLIONS OF PAGES, WE
FOUND NOTHING.
IF THEY WERE UP HAVE FOUND ONE
BAD SENTENCE OUT OF MILLIONS OF
PAGES, BELIEVE ME, IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN FRONT AND CENTER.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN FRONT AND
CENTER.
BUT IT'S TRUE, WHEN I, ON
NOVEMBER 8TH, PROCTOR B, ONE OF
THE GREAT
NIGHTS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
HAD, SINCE THEY CAME FROM THE
HILLS IN THE MOUNTAINS, THEY
CAME FROM THE VALLEYS, THEY CAME
FROM EVERYWHERE, SEAN.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE EVENING.
THEY HAVE BEEN REWARDED BECAUSE
OUR JOB NUMBERS, OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS, ALL OF THE
NUMBERS THAT THEY REALLY WANTED
ARE THE BEST WE HAVE EVER HAD.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS, I SAID, YOU
KNOW, LET'S GET BACK ON, LET'S
NOT THINK ABOUT THE PAST, LET'S
THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE.
BUT NOW I THINK THINKING ABOUT
THE PAST IS JUST OKAY BECAUSE WE
CAN NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN AGAIN
IN OUR COUNTRY OR TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ME.
I'M TALKING INTO THE FUTURE.
WE CAN NEVER ALLOW THIS
TREASONOUS -- THESE TREASONOUS
ACTS TO HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED TAKEOVER
OF OUR GOVERNMENT, OF OUR
COUNTRY, AND ILLEGAL TAKEOVER.
IF IT WERE THE OTHER WAY AROUND,
WHERE I WAS DOING IT TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA OR A DEMOCRAT,
IT WOULD BE VIRTUALLY THE
MAXIMUM SENTENCE THAT YOU CAN
FIND NO MATTER WHERE YOU LOOK IN
WHATEVER LEGAL BOOK.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU NOW, I
WAS VERY CRITICAL OF THE TEAM
THAT ROBERT MUELLER PUT
TOGETHER.
YOU MENTIONED ANDREW WEISSMANN,
I GOT THE RACE RECORD.
WAS AT HILLARY CLINTON'S VICTORY
PARTY.
ONLY DEMOCRATIC DONORS -- NO
REPUBLICANS AT ALL, AND OVER
PUBLIC AND VOTERS -- ALSO
JEANNIE RHEE WHO WORK FOR THE
CODE THE FOUNDATION IS A LAWYER
WAS APPOINTED.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT MUELLER
TODAY AND WERE YOU SURPRISED AT
ALL, CONSIDERING THE TEAM THAT
HE PICKED IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE?
IT SEEMED PRETTY PARTISAN
DEMOCRAT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
UNFAIR TO PICK THAT BIASED
A-TEAM.
>> President Trump: YEAH, IT
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE BIASED.
>> Sean: DOES A GOOD POINT.
>> President Trump: IT WAS
TREMENDOUSLY ANTI-TRUMP.
IT WAS NEVER TRUMPERS, IT WAS
ANTI-TRUMP.
I THINK IN EVERY SINGLE
INSTANCE, I KNOW THAT ANDREW
WEISSMANN WAS AT HER -- I GUESS
HE WOULD CALL IT THE WAY, WHICH
WAS THE BIG EVENING ON NOVEMBER
NOVEMBER 8TH, HE WAS THERE TO
CELEBRATE A VICTORY, HE WAS
THERE, AND NOT A HAPPY CAMPER.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
CONTRIBUTED, MOST OF THEM,
CONTRIBUTED TO HER CAMPAIGN.
I MEAN, IT WAS A SHOCKING TO SEE
IT.
SO I WASN'T EXACTLY SURE -- I
KNOW ONE THING, I HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH RUSSIA, BUT I WASN'T
EXACTLY -- WHEN I LOOKED AT THE
TEAM THAT WAS ASSEMBLED, I
WASN'T EXACTLY SURE -- MAYBE
THEY WOULD TAKE A SENTENCE FROM
HERE AND A SENTENCE
I HAD NO IDEA.
I KNOW ONE THING, I WAS THE MOST
INNOCENT HUMAN BEING -- AND THEY
ALL SAID IT, EVEN COMEY SAID HE
FOUND NO WRONGDOING -- AND ONE
OF THE FEW TIMES HE DIDN'T LIKE
HIM BECAUSE HE LIED IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS, JOHN BRENNAN LIED,
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE LIED TO
CONGRESS AND NOTHING HAPPENED.
AND YET WITH FLYNN, WHERE THEY
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IF HE LIED
BASED ON --
>> Sean: HE DIDN'T.
>> President Trump: WHAT THE
REPORTS ARE, AND OTHERS, LOOKS
WHAT HAPPENED THE OTHER SIDE.
THESE PEOPLE WITH SO MANY LIES,
AND LIES BEFORE CONGRESS, WHICH
IS JUST ABOUT THE ULTIMATE,
SWORN TESTIMONY WHERE COMEY TOLD
SO MUCH, AND HE LEAKED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION!
WELL, IF SOMEBODY IN OUR TEAM
LEAKED CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
IT WOULD BE YEARS IN JAIL!
SO NOBODY CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT
WENT ON.
NOBODY REALLY UNDERSTANDS ONE OF
OTHER THING, WHEN THE REPORT
CAME OUT, WHY DIDN'T THEY LOOK
AT ALL OF THESE ACTS ON THE OTHR
SIDE?
WISE IF THEY ONLY LOOKED
AT OUR PEOPLE?
ALL OF THAT BEING SAID, THE END
RESULT, IT TOOK A LONG TIME,
ALMOST TWO YEARS, BUT THE END
RESULT IS NO COLLUSION, AND NO
OBSTRUCTION.
BUT IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET
THERE.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO RELEASE THE
FISA APPLICATIONS.
THERE WAS THE ORIGINAL
APPLICATIONS, THE THREE
SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL APPLICATIONS.
WE ARE TOLD, ANDREW McCABE
SAID, NO DOSSIER, NO FISA
WARRANT.
THAT WAS A BACKDOOR TO YOUR
CAMPAIGN BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THE DOSSIER ALSO WAS LEAKED TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," PARTS OF
IT, TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
OF COURSE, NEVER VERIFIED.
DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO RELEASE
THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS, GANG OF
EIGHT INFORMATION, THE 30 TRUES
OF BRUCE OHR AND OTHERS, THE
FIVE BUCKETS ARE JOHN SOLOMON
AND SARA CARTER, AS THEY
CALL IT?
>> President Trump: I DO, I
HAVE PLANS TO DECLASSIFY AND
RELEASE.
I HAVE PLANS TO ABSOLUTELY
BUT I HAVE SOME VERY TALENTED
PEOPLE WORKING FOR ME, LAWYERS.
AND THEY REALLY DIDN'T WANT ME
TO DO IT EARLY ON.
DEVIN NUNES, BY THE WAY, AND
MEADOWS, YOU LOOK AT JIM JORDAN,
AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE, THEY
WORKED SO HARD.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTED ME TO DO
IT A LONG TIME AGO.
I'M GLAD I DIDN'T DO IT.
WE GOT A GREAT RESULT WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO IT BUT WE WELL.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT MY
LAWYERS DIDN'T WANT ME TO DO IT,
THEY SAID, IF I DO IT, THEY WILL
CALL IT A FORM OF OBSTRUCTION,
SO THEY WILL SAY, OH, YOU
RELEASED THESE DOCUMENTS SO WE
WOULD MAKE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION TRANSPARENT.
YOU KNOW, AND POLITICS YOU
ALWAYS HEAR TRANSPARENCY.
IT WOULD MAKE IT TRANSPARENT.
AND THEN THEY CALL IT
OBSTRUCTION, KNOWING THE PEOPLE
WE ARE DEALING WITH.
SO FRANKLY, I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE BETTER IF WE HELD IT TO THE
END.
NO, BUT AT THE RIGHT TIME, WE
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY RELEASING IT.
I DID THE RIGHT THING BY NOT
DOING IT SO FAR.
BUT YOU UNDERSTAND, THEY WOULD
CALL IT SOMETHING THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE.
IT'S THE ONLY TIME YOU WOULD BE
TRANSPARENT WHERE THEY WOULD SAY
BAD THINGS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, DUE TO
TESTIMONY, THANKS TO GEORGIA
REPUBLICAN COLLINS, WE NOW HAVE
TESTIMONY, ONE THING THAT
SHOCKED ME A LITTLE BIT LAST
WEEK WAS THE TESTIMONY OF STRZOK
AND PAGE WERE BOTH OF THEM
SUGGESTING THE FIX WAS IN ON
HILLARY, BECAUSE IT WAS BEING --
EVERY DECISION WAS BEING RUN
THROUGH THE AG'S OFFICE.
THAT MEANS LORETTA LYNCH, WHO
ALSO MET ON THE TARMAC WAS
BILL CLINTON, WHICH BRINGS US TO
A HIGHER LEVEL THAN MAYBE WE
ONCE THOUGHT.
ANY REACTION TO THAT WITH
LORETTA LYNCH, APPARENTLY,
ACCORDING TO STRZOK AND PAGE,
RUNNING THE SHOW, MAKING
DECISIONS FOR THE FBI AT THE
TIME?
THE INTERACTION BETWEEN COMEY
AND LORETTA LYNCH WHEN SHE SAID
IT'S AN INVESTIGATION AND SHE
SAID, NO, IT'S A MATTER.
>> Sean: FIRST OF ALL, DOUG
COLLINS IS FANTASTIC, THE JOB HE
IS DOING.
HE'S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
I WISH HE WERE CHAIRMAN BUT HE'S
NOT.
BUT WE ARE NOT OFF A MATCH.
I THINK WE ALL RETAKE THE HOUSE
BECAUSE THEY SEE WHAT WE'VE DONE
AND WE SEE THE CONFUSION AND
EVERYTHING.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS
INVESTIGATE AND NOW THE
INVESTIGATION IS TURNING OUT TO
BE SOMETHING THAT IS NOT VERY
GOOD.
NANCY PELOSI IS SMART, SHE'S
RIGHT AND WHAT SHE IS SAYING
BECAUSE, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
ESPECIALLY NOW AFTER THIS GREAT
RESULT, BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW --
YOU JUST CAN'T, WHEN YOU SEE THE
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, YOU JUST DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO GET A NO
COLLUSION ANSWER.
A STRONG NO COLLUSION ANSWER.
BUT I WILL SAY, I WANT TO THANK
DOUG COLLINS.
I WILL ALSO SAY, YOU START
TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
ON THE TARMAC.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THEY A LOT OF
BAD THINGS HAPPEN ON THE TARMAC
BETWEEN LORETTA LYNCH AND
BILL CLINTON.
I HAD A LOT OF PLANES VERY LONG
TIME.
I'VE NEVER STOPPED THE PLANE ON
THE TARMAC TO LET SOMEBODY ON
THE PLANE.
THEN THEY WANTED THEY TALKED
ABOUT GOLF AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN FOR 40 MINUTES.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
WHAT DO THEY TALK ABOUT?
AND THEN SHE WAS EXONERATED.
SHE WAS GIVEN ONE OF THE GREAT
FREE PASSES OF ALL TIME.
I GUESS BILL CLINTON SAID HE WAS
THERE TO PLAY GOLF, BUT I KNOW
THE AREA VERY WELL, ARIZONA.
IT'S A LITTLE WARM AT THAT TIME
OF THE YEAR FOR GOLF, OKAY?
PEOPLE -- A LOT OF PEOPLE -- IS
A GREAT STATE, I LOVE IT, BUT
YOU ARE NOT PLAYING A LOT OF
GOLF RIGHT THERE AT THAT TIME.
SO YOU HAVE TO FIND OUT, WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE BACK OF THAT
PLANE THAT SO MANY THINGS TOOK
PLACE AFTER THAT INCIDENT, THAT
MEETING BETWEEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL LYNCH AND
BILL CLINTON PRAYED A LOT OF BAD
THINGS HAPPENED RIGHT AFTER
THAT.
YOU HAVE TO FIND OUT FOR YOU
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS, AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
OUR COUNTRY THAT THOSE THINGS BE
DETERMINED AND FOUND OUT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION ABOUT
PEOPLE -- IF YOU DON'T MIND, I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT SENSITIVE
ISSUES.
A COUPLE OF BIG THINGS HAPPENED
IN IMMIGRATION AND HEALTH CARE
THIS WEEK.
THE LAST TWO, WE KNOW THAT
CLAPPER LIED UNDER OATH.
I BELIEVE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS, THOUGH, HAS PASSED.
IN THE CASE OF JOHN BRENNAN, WE
KNOW THAT THERE WAS
SURVEILLANCE, UNMASKING, LEAKING
RAW INTELLIGENCE, AN INCREASE OF
350% OF UNMASKING, SAMANTHA
POWERS, WHO WAS WORKING FOR THE
U.N., ASKING FOR 300 CASES
UNMASKED.
SHE DENIES IT.
BUT IN THAT PARTICULAR CASE OF
BRENNAN AND CLAPPER, AND BRENNAN
IN PARTICULAR, MULTIPLE TIMES
ACCUSED YOU OF TREASON.
YOUR REACTION?
>> President Trump: WELL, I
THINK BRENNAN IS A SICK PERSON.
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
FOR HIM.
FOR HIM TO COME OUT OF THE CIA
AN ACT THAT WAY WAS SO
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE COUNTRY
INTO THE CIA INTO THE POSITION
HE HELD AND HE WAS NOT
CONSIDERED GOOD AT WHAT HE DID.
HE WAS NEVER RESPECTED GUY.
TOUGH GUY BUT NOT A RESPECTED
GUY.
BUT HE LIED TO CONGRESS.
THE OTHER NIGHT BEFORE THE
REPORT CAME OUT, HE PREDICTED
HORRIBLE THINGS.
THINGS HE SAID WERE HORRIBLE.
THEN TODAY, I GUESS HE SAID
SOMETHING -- I DIDN'T SEE IT BUT
I HEARD HE SAID, WELL, I MUST
HAVE BAD SOURCES OR BAD
INFORMATION.
I MEAN, THIS IS A MAN WHO REALLY
IS EITHER SICK OR THERE IS SOME
OTHER PROBLEM.
BUT THE WAY HE SPOKE -- AND AS
YOU KNOW, CLAPPER LIED, AND
PERHAPS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS RAN OUT ON THAT ONE
BUT IT DIDN'T RUN OUT ON COMEY,
IT DIDN'T RUN OUT ON BRENNAN OR
STRZOK OR PAGE OR McCABE.
McCABE, HIS WIFE GOT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
HE WAS RUNNING THE FBI AND
RUNNING ALL SORTS OF CASES AND
HIS WIFE GOT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FROM A
CENTRALLY CLINTONS, FROM
QUENTIN'S CLOSEST FRIEND.
THEN HE RULED SO FAVORABLY.
HE TRIED TO SAY HE WAS NOT
INVOLVED, I DON'T THINK TOO MANY
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT, I DID NOT
BELIEVE THAT.
BUT SHE GOT ALL THOSE GOOD
RULINGS.
IT'S REALLY A SCANDALOUS
SITUATION.
IT IS SO BADLY THAT IT REFLECTS
IT SO HORRIBLY, A GUY LIKE BRUCE
OHR WITH HIS WIFE, NELLIE OHR,
AND GPS FUSION.
SHE WROTE THE REPORT, GOALS,
GIVES IT TO HER HUSBAND WHO IS
AT THE DOJ, AND THEN SHE GOES
AND BRINGS IT TO THE FBI,
AND SHE'S GETTING PAID FOR DOING
IT.
IT'S INCREDIBLE, THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED ARE INCREDIBLE, AND
VERY, VERY BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: I HOPE YOU ARE RIGHT.
I THINK WE GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T, AND THE MEDIA HAS BEEN NO
HELP, THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL -- IF I MAY MOVE ONTO A
COUPLE COUPLE OF ISSUES,
CONSERVATIVES, WOULD YOU HAD A
35 DAY SHUTDOWN, YOU ARE
INVITING NANCY PELOSI,
CHUCK SCHUMER TO SIT WITH YOU.
YOU PUT DACA ON THE TABLE,
DREAMERS ON THE TABLE, THEY SAID
THEY WANT TO DEFER OR AVOID
EMPLOYEES PAID AFTER 35
DAYS, YOU DECIDED THE STRATEGY
IS NOT WORKING.
I WAS PRETTY CONFIDENT, I THINK
I HAVE KNOWN YOU WELL, YOU ARE
JUST CHANGING STRATEGIES.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THEY COULD NOT
OVERRIDE THE VETO AND THAT MEANS
HOW MUCH MONEY NOW IS AVAILABLE
FOR THE WALL AND WHAT IS THE
STATUS, THE PROGRESS, HOW MANY
MORE MILES NEED TO BE BUILT, HOW
MANY HAVE YOU REPAIRED, HOW
MANY -- WHERE ARE WE ON ALL OF
THIS?
>> President Trump: WE HAVE
REPAIRED LITERALLY -- MANY, MANY
MILES.
I COULD GIVE YOU NUMBERS BUT
MANY, MANY MILES.
WE ARE BUILDING MANY MILES.
WE WILL HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILES
ALREADY UNDER CONSTRUCTION ARE
SOON TO BE UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WILL BE
NECESSARY.
IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER, IT'S TERRIBLE WITH THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, THE DRUGS,
EVERYTHING THAT IS COMING
ACROSS, AND THAT GOES ACROSS THE
SOFT POINTS, WHICH ARE THE
POINTS WITHOUT THE WALL.
WE WILL HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILES
BUILT FAIRLY QUICKLY.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE TOOK A BILLION DOLLARS IN
TODAY, AND I'M BUILDING AND MUCH
LESS EXPENSIVELY THAN IT WAS IN
THE PAST.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PAST, THEY
WERE LOOKING AT 25 TO
$30 BILLION.
I'M BUILDING IT FOR A FRACTION
OF THAT.
THE WALL IS BETTER.
IT'S GOING UP FASTER.
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS IS
DOING A GREAT JOB WORKING WITH
US AND WE HAVE SOME REAL
PROFESSIONALS, AND THE MILITARY
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE, PUTTING UP
THE BARBED WIRE, ESSENTIALLY,
IT'S BARBED WIRE.
IT'S ACTUALLY BARB WIRE
PLUS.
IT'S INCREDIBLE WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
YOU HAVE SEEN IT.
MANY, MANY MILES OF WIRE.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE IT, WE WOULD
REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM.
BUT WE ARE REALLY CAPTURING --
LET'S USE THE WORD CAPTURING --
WE ARE CAPTURING PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING IN ILLEGALLY, WE ARE NOT
JUST RELEASING THEM, IN SOME
CASES, WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
ROOM, AND MANY CASES NOW WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF ROOM.
THE LAWS ARE SO BAD, NORMALLY
YOU JUST BRING THEM BACK BY THE
LAWS DON'T LET YOU DO THAT, OUR
LAWS THAT COULD BE EASILY
CHANGED BY THE DEMOCRATS, BUT
THEY ARE SO BAD AND SO CORRUPT
ON IMMIGRATION, WHETHER IT IS
CATCH AND RELEASE OR CHAIN
MIGRATION OR ANY OF THE VARIOUS
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO PUT UP
WITH, IT'S TERRIBLE.
BUT WE ARE DOING FANTASTIC.
WE ARE BUILDING -- IN FACT, INTO
WEEKS, I'M GOING TO A LOCATION,
IT'S GOING TO BE IN CALIFORNIA,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THEY WERE
BEGGING US TO BUILD IN
SAN DIEGO, BEGGING US TO BUILD A
WALL AND WE ARE JUST IN THE
PROCESS OF COMPLETING A MAJOR
STRETCH OF MANY MILES OF WALL,
AND WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A NEWS
CONFERENCE THERE JUST TO SHOW
PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY GOOD STUFF.
IT'S BETTER, LESS EXPENSIVE,
GOES UP FASTER, BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY BETTER THAN WHAT THEY
WERE DOING BEFORE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE IT DONE
AND WE ARE IN GREAT SHAPE.
WE GOT A GREAT SUPPORT FROM THE
REPUBLICANS, BOTH IN CONGRESS,
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR CONGRESSMEN
AND WOMEN AND FROM THE SENATE.
I REALLY HAD GREAT SUPPORT.
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE VOTED AGAINST
BUT THAT'S OKAY, THEY HAD THEIR
REASONS.
WE HAD GREAT SUPPORT.
>> Sean: YOU WILL BE ABLE TO
USE, ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE, A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS --
>> President Trump: MANY
BILLIONS, YEP.
MANY BILLIONS.
YOU GO TO A LOT OF THE GENERALS,
THEY WILL TELL YOU, THIS IS A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
WE NEED TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE POURING IN.
I MEAN, THEY ARE POURING -- WE
ARE CAPTURING THESE PEOPLE, WE
ARE GETTING THERE.
BUT WE DON'T DO LIKE OTHER
COUNTRIES, OTHER COUNTRIES STAND
THERE WITH MACHINE GUNS READY TO
FIRE.
WE CAN'T DO THAT AND I WOULDN'T
WANT TO DO THAT, OKAY?
IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY OF
DOING IT AND I WOULDN'T WANT TO
DO IT.
WE CAN'T DO IT.
IF WE HAVE BARRIERS, WE HAVE THE
WALLS LIKE WE ARE BUILDING NOW,
AND BUILDING -- A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T THINK WE ARE BUILDING
WALLS, WE ARE BUILDING MASSIVE,
MANY, MANY MILES OF WALLS RIGHT
NOW, AND WE ARE GEARING UP TO DO
MANY MORE.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILES OF
WALLS BUILT IN THE VERY NEAR --
BUILT AND RENOVATED, TOO, A LOT
OF IT, WE WERE ABLE TO USE THE
OLD CARCASS OF A WALL.
WE FIXED IT AND FOR A SMALLER
AMOUNT OF MONEY, WE WERE ABLE TO
BUILD A WALL THAT IS LITERALLY
JUST AS GOOD AS NEW.
SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK ON
IT, AND A LOT OF TALENT HAS BEEN
INVOLVED, AND WE'VE HAD REALLY A
TREMENDOUS HELP, A LOT OF PEOPLE
AGREE.
I MEAN, MOST PEOPLE AGREE.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS AGREE.
THEY DON'T SAY THAT.
THEY GO INTO BACK ROOMS, LIKE I
SAID BEFORE ABOUT SCHIFF, THEY
GO BACK THERE AND THEY LAUGH BUT
THEY GO INTO THE ROOM AND
LAUGH -- EVERYONE KNOWS YOU NEED
THE WALL BY THE DEMOCRATS COME
ALMOST EVERY ONE OF THEM VOTED
FOR THE WALLS IN THE PAST.
BUT NOW THEY DON'T BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO GIVE US A VICTORY.
BUT THEY ARE HURTING THE
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT HURTING ME, THEY
ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE NEW GREEN DEAL,
YOU SEE THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO CHALLENGE YOU IN 2020.
PROPOSALS OF AS HIGH AS A 70%
TOP MARGINAL TAX RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS, 90% FOR
CORPORATIONS, A WEALTH TAX, THE
NEW GREEN DEAL SAYS NO OIL, NO
GAS, AT ALL.
WE ARE NOW ENERGY INDEPENDENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OVER 70
YEARS, AND THE EXPORT OF ENERGY
BECAUSE OF ENDING BUREAUCRACY
AND REGULATIONS, AND THEN
EVERYTHING IS FREE, EVERYTHING,
AND ON TOP OF THAT, WE ARE GOING
TO GET RID OF THE COMBUSTION
ENGINE, AND WE ARE GOING TO ALSO
GET RID OF PERHAPS COWS AND
AIRPLANES AND WE ARE GOING TO
BUILD HIGH-SPEED TRAINS AND JUST
MEDICARE FOR ALL WITH NO OTHER
CHOICES.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION, AS YOU
WATCH THIS NEW GREEN DEAL AND
THE COMMENTS OF ALL THESE NEW
CANDIDATES?
DO YOU HAVE A NEW REACTION TO
HIS?
>> President Trump: WELL, I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK BADLY ABOUT
THE NEW GREEN DEAL, SEAN,
BECAUSE, FRANKLY, I'M AFRAID
THEY WILL STOP USING IT, BECAUSE
I REALLY DO WANT TO CAMPAIGN
AGAINST IT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, ALL RIGHT, IT'S
CRAZY.
IT WILL COST $100 TRILLION.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THAT MEANS.
THAT MEANS IS MORE MONEY THAN
YOU HAVE IN THE WORLD.
AND IT WILL BE CATASTROPHIC.
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S JUST TALK.
OF COURSE, THEY WILL CAMPAIGN ON
IT, THEY WILL SAY, WE'LL GIVE
FREE EVERYTHING, YOU'LL END UP
BEING VENEZUELA IF THAT IS
HAPPENING.
WE HAVE A NICE BIG PROBLEM WITH
VENEZUELA.
YOU LOOK AT VENEZUELA, WAS A
WEALTHY COUNTRY NOT LONG AGO,
AND NOW IT'S ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTRIES.
WE'LL END UP BEING THE SAME
THING.
THE NEW GREEN DEAL IS
RIDICULOUS, BUT I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK BADLY BECAUSE I WANT THEM
TO KEEP GOING FORWARD WITH IT.
I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CAMPAIGNING, JUST A LITTLE BIT
EARLY, JUST LIKE
ELIZABETH WARREN.
I HIT HER TOO HARD TO EARLY, AND
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S
FINISHED.
I WISH SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
THE RACE AND FRANKLY, I WOULD
HAVE LOVED TO HAVE RUN AGAINST
HER BUT I WOULD SAY SHE'S
PROBABLY FINISHED.
BUT THEY HAVE PLENTY LEFT.
NEW GREEN DEAL IS GOING NOWHERE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, MANY
PRESIDENTS HAVE PROMISED ISRAEL
THAT THEY WOULD MOVE THE CAPITAL
FROM TEL AVIV TO JERUSALEM.
YOU MADE A TOUGH POSITION, YOU
GOT THAT DONE, I HAVE DRAWN THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL
PERSONALLY FOR WELL OVER 20
YEARS.
LIKE I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR WELL
OVER 20 YEARS.
I'VE ALWAYS VIEWED
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU AS A
CHURCHILLIAN FIGURE WITH MORAL
CLARITY, THAT FEW PEOPLE HAD ON
THE WORLD STAGE, STANDING ALONE
OFTEN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A VERY BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THE GOLAN
HEIGHTS BEING ISRAEL'S TERRITOR
TERRITORY.
AS YOU SEE THE RISE OF
ANTI-SEMITISM, NOT JUST -- WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT
HAVE SAID HORRIBLE THINGS, BUT
IN EUROPE, AND ELSEWHERE, AND
THE DANGERS OF THAT SMALL
COUNTRY, RADICAL ISLAM, I JUST
WANTED TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF ISRAEL AS OUR
CLOSE ALLY.
>> President Trump: WELL, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES WHEN YOU SEE WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY,
YESTERDAY, I WAS VERY HONORED TO
DO THE GOLAN HEIGHTS.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
PROMISED BY MANY, MANY
PRESIDENTS OVER MANY, MANY
YEARS, AND I GOT IT DONE.
THEN YOU LOOK AT ALSO JERUSALEM,
MOVING THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM,
FOR YEARS, MANY PRESIDENTS FOR
MANY DECADES CAMPAIGNED ON IT.
THEY WERE GOING TO DO IT AND
THEY NEVER DID IT BECAUSE
FRANKLY, IT WAS MUCH TOUGHER TO
DO THAN PEOPLE WHATEVER EVER
UNDERSTAND.
IT WAS VERY TOUGH.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ULTIMATELY
DIDN'T DO IT, DIDN'T GET IT
DONE, BUT I GOT IT DONE.
NOT ONLY DID I GET IT DONE, I
GOT THE EMBASSY BELT FOR A
FRACTION, A TINY, TINY
FRACTION OF WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO COST AN OUTCOME AS YOU KNOW,
THE EMBASSY IS OPEN.
IS NOT JUST AS IT PAINTED, IT'S
OPEN IN JERUSALEM.
SO I AM VERY PROUD OF WHAT WE
HAVE DONE FOR ISRAEL, I'M VERY
PROUD OF MY RELATIONSHIP WITH
ISRAEL, AND WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE DEMOCRATS, AND WITH
JEWISH PEOPLE AND THE DEMOCRATS
AND ISRAEL IS A SHOCKING TO ME.
I GREW UP IN A WORLD WHERE
PEOPLE REALLY -- AND DEMOCRATS,
THEY LOVED ISRAEL, AND NOW I'M
LOOKING AT A WORLD WHERE MANY
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO HATE ISRAEL.
THEY SEEM TO DESPISE ISRAEL.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS SURPRISE TO
ME.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ISRAEL AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC.
TERRIBLE.
>> Sean: I MEANT TO ASK YOU
EARLIER, DEVIN NUNES, WHO'S BEEN
ON THIS SHOW MANY TIMES, AND I
THINK HAS BEEN -- WHEN HE WAS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, HE WROTE AND WARNED
EVERYBODY, WE HAVE WATCHED
RUSSIA OVER THE YEARS, A HOSTILE
REGIME, HOSTILE ACTOR ON THE
WORLD STAGE, WE KNOW THAT
BARACK OBAMA, CAUGHT ON THE
MICROPHONE SAYING, I'LL HAVE A
LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN MY NEXT
TERM, AND THEN THE CASE OF
SCHIFF BEING CAUGHT ON TAPE
COLLUDING, TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU TO IMPACT
ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE HAVE KNOWN
THAT THEY HAVE IMPACTED OTHER
NATIONS' ELECTION'S.
DEVIN NUNES WARNED THIS COUNTRY
ABOUT HOW HOSTILE THEY ARE ON
OUR ELECTIONS.
WE NEED FREE, FAIR ELECTIONS.
WE DO KNOW THAT THEY TRIED,
ATTEMPTED TO INFLUENCE,
SEEMINGLY ON BOTH SIDES, HOW DO
WE PREVENT THEM?
WE HAVE 250,000 I.T. PEOPLE
WORKING FOR OUR GOVERNMENT.
HOW DO WE NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO STOP THIS TYPE OF HOSTILITY
COMING FROM FOREIGN POWERS,
HOSTILE REGIMES LIKE RUSSIA?
>> President Trump: FIRST OF
ALL, LET ME SAY THAT DEVIN NUNES
IS SOMEDAY GOING TO BE HAILED AS
A GREAT AMERICAN HERO.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY THAT MAN
BECAUSE HE SPOKE UP FOR GOOD AND
JUST AND ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE TO SPEAK UP FOR.
BUT MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO IT.
HE WILL BE SOMEDAY HAILED AS A
GREAT AMERICAN HERO, WHAT HE
DID.
THEY TRIED TO RUIN HIM.
THEY TRIED TO DESTROY HIM.
THEY TRIED TO RUIN HIS LIFE AND
HIS FAMILY.
HE JUST KEPT PLUGGING LIKE THERE
WAS NOTHING GOING ON.
I MEAN, IT WAS AN AMAZING THING.
AS FAR AS YOUR OTHER PART OF THE
QUESTION, AND SEPTEMBER, IF YOU
LOOK, SUPPOSEDLY, THE FBI TOLD
PRESIDENT OBAMA ALL ABOUT RUSSIA
TRYING TO GET INVOLVED IN SOME
FORM IN THE ELECTION, AND HE
DECIDED TO DO NOTHING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO
WIN.
SO HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT THAT CLINTON
WAS GOING TO END AND HE DIDN'T
WANT TO UPSET THE APPLE CART.
BUT HE KNEW ABOUT IT.
AND THE QUESTION IS, ONE OF THE
MANY, MANY QUESTIONS, AND THIS
IS PROBABLY NOT AS BIG AS OTHER
QUESTIONS, BECAUSE YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT MAJOR, MAJOR
TREASON AND CORRUPT -- ALL THE
THINGS.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS, WHY DIDN'T
HE DO SOMETHING?
HE KNEW ABOUT IT.
THIS WASN'T UP TO ME.
I WASN'T PRESIDENT WHEN ALL THIS
WAS HAPPENING.
WHY DIDN'T PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DO
SOMETHING WHEN THEY WERE
INFORMED ABOUT RUSSIA AND THE
ELECTION?
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT, I ONLY
HAVE ABOUT ANOTHER MINUTE AND A
HALF.
THANK YOU FOR BEING SO GENEROUS
WITH YOUR TIME.
WILL YOU MAKE IT A PRIORITY
BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ELECTION
INTEGRITY AND BEEF UP OUR
DEFENSES AS A COUNTRY, SO NO FOR
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND H
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND W
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND I
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND P
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND R
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND A
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND T
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND I
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND S
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND T
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND A
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND ,
AN ENTITY HAVE ANY IMPACT, AND D
THE STEPS THAT YOU ARE THINKING
ABOUT TAKING?
>> President Trump: I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
RUSSIA OR ANYBODY ELSE HAD NO
IMPACT ON VOICE.
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO KNOW.
THAT HAS BEEN COMING OUT, AS YOU
KNOW, FROM EVERY AGENCY,
EVERYBODY THAT HAS DONE IT.
SO WHETHER THEY TRIED, AND HOW
HARD THEY TRIED, AND
PRESIDENT OBAMA KNEW, THE BOTTOM
LINE IS, THEY HAD A ZERO IMPACT
ON THE ELECTION OF 2016.
I'M VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE ALL ABOUT.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
IN ANY WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM.
BUT WE ARE PUTTING VERY STRONG
SAFEGUARDS AND, THIS SOUNDS A
LITTLE OLD-FASHIONED, BUT THE
BEST BACKUP IS A PAPER BACK UP,
NOT A COMPUTER BACK UP, AND WE
HAVE MANY PAPER BACKUPS, JUST IN
CASE THERE IS A PROBLEM,
SOMETHING WHICH THEY DIDN'T HAVE
BEFORE.
BUT WE ARE BEING VERY VIGILANT
AND WORKING VERY HARD, AND WE
HAVE TREMENDOUS SYSTEMS IN
PLACE.
>> Sean: 10-SECOND ANSWER.
WILL YOU GET NOW, THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON OBAMACARE,
JOINING WITH A COURT DECISION,
WILL WE GET THAT DONE?
WE ONLY HAVE TEN SECONDS.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
GOING TO DO GREAT.
WE ARE GOING ALONG WITH TEXAS,
WE ARE WINNING THE CASE, AND WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE GREAT
HEALTH CARE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WILL BE THE
PARTY OF GREAT HEALTH CARE.
YOU WATCH.
>> Sean: AND PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS AND CHOICES?
>> President Trump: ALL
INCLUDED.
WE WILL HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS ABSOLUTELY AND WE
ALREADY GOT RID OF THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE, WHICH WAS
COSTING PEOPLE A FORTUNE, IT WAS
TERRIBLE.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME